well it's time for the safety blitz to
get a whole lot smarter now as we
welcome karen guerigian from the boston
herald of course rodney harrison
two-time super bowl champ i'm jack
collinsworth so a buffalo loss and a
heartbreaking loss for the bills a new
england win in prime time what is the
state of the afc east right now in your
mind's eye karen
well uh buffalo's gonna have a
tough time maybe it's a good thing they
have a bye week
to come back from such a devastating
loss either that or
you know that might play in their heads
a little bit going forward
i actually think the dolphins are the
bigger uh challenge to the bills in the
immediate future and the patriots
stay tuned uh
it definitely helped them to beat
the ravens
and right now they're establishing a
little bit of momentum a little bit of
confidence so we'll see
it's it's not impossible
i think their better avenue getting in
uh might be a wild card
karen yesterday i thought coach bill did
his best coaching job of the season the
team looked prepared and they really
look ready to go what did you see from
well i it's funny cam newton after the
game called him the football whisperer
and and maybe you can relate to that
rodney because
whatever bill is talking about during
the week whatever he's preaching
even if it sounds ridiculous to the
players
uh tends to come true during game time
and
you know players you know why are we
doing this why are we doing this
well everything belichick tends to say
happens
even to the point where he's able to
dial up his tsunami
cam newton when you look at his numbers
his numbers weren't great but what is it
about cam that has made him
so attractive in that locker room so
many people like him why does coach
belichick just really just
fawn over cam newton like he does
well i mean he is a former nfl mvp but
he he really cam really engages his
teammates whether it's calling him a
nickname or doing a secret handshake
with them
i mean he's really an engaging
charismatic type of person
even to the point of how he dresses
obviously
but i think
the players like
he's really relatable to them
and it's almost like they're all in this
together
and he doesn't present himself above
anybody he's one of them
and he's
you know i think the players get a lot
of encouragement from him and you see a
player like jacoby myers really flourish
and blossom uh with cam
yeah jacoby certainly has and i want to
play this sound right now karen i really
want to ask you about the new england
passing game and how much do you think
they're going to need down the stretch
to maybe make some kind of a deep
playoff push here but let's hear right
now from cam newton on the jacobi myers
touchdown as you guys were talking about
it
xyz jacoby looked and he was like
huh he said yeah we got you know the
play was called
and then he looked down he was like
damn
i got hold on say everybody looking at
him look at his gloves he's like bro i
gotta take off one of my gloves he took
out one of his gloves so it's like
you want my warm pouch so you can keep
your hands dry he's like no no no
able hold my second glove too it was it
was just like we had a moment at the
offense in that hurdle because we was
coming off a tv timeout and jacoby was
like i'm like bro relax and if you don't
got nobody just throw it to your check
down which is me and i'm gonna make
something out of it so when the play was
called when the play was snapped
somebody went straight to me so i was
like damn jacob you ain't got nobody so
just throw it
and cam newton really is a great
storyteller i i always thought he never
gets enough credit for his ability to
tell stories a great personality really
to listen to
so you heard him talking right there
sometimes you got to take off the glove
it's a little concerning though when
your biggest play in the passing game
comes from a wide receiver throw in the
football did they have enough in the
tank this is a pure passing attack to
make a deep playoff push do you think
karen
i don't think that that i don't i really
don't think that's their identity
i think
you saw it in that game it's smash mouth
bully ball football
their best asset in the on the offense
is their offensive line and their
fleet of running backs
so that's where they're stuck they're
going to start from that point and if
they can if they're effective playing
that smash mouth style
that will open up enough avenues uh for
cam newton to throw the ball to let's
face it a group of receivers that aren't
anywhere close to the top five that you
just mentioned a little while ago
karen it seemed like they played a lot
more zone yesterday trying to keep lamar
in front of them what is their biggest
weakness when you look on the defensive
side of the ball we know about
their cornerbacks and their ability to
play one-on-one but when you look in
totality of their defense what is their
biggest weakness
they don't have speed and they don't
have play makers i mean it's it's it's
in their front seven and i think
they
they didn't allow
uh
the ravens to spread the ball out they
they tried to make uh lamar play in like
a phone booth and they tried to compress
the field for him uh
and it and it got the job done enough
they weren't they didn't want him to
make any big big plays like they did he
did on them last year particularly with
his legs i think his longest run was
maybe 11 yards or something like that
but
in front of him they compress the field
and uh again the patriots don't have
speed if it's a track meet they're going
to lose
so
that's where
bill belichick's brain comes in
and that's where his scheming in
plotting also comes into play and in
if the players execute and do what
they're told they'll have a chance
yeah karen that's great stuff and it's
tsunami no tsunami figuring out a way to
get a win sunday night football a win is
a win really appreciate you taking some
time look forward to the next one
thanks gary
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports